house used to be i loved it houston was
great um
did you link up with whiskey pete i
didn't you see him at all no i hung with
dan crenshaw
nice nice guy and by the way uh i'm i'm
not a far-right [ __ ] you know i have
no idea what his politics are he was
just you know his politics i mean
what i like about him we all know what i
like about him you're like i didn't know
the guy i actually don't i actually
don't i like no it's politics dang crazy
you know he's not a far left liberal i
know his father
well for me i'm not a i'm not far left
and i'm not far i'm not right i'm i'm
moderate i don't think i've ever
i'm not
politically i'm moderate i just am like
i'm pro gay man
all that [ __ ] yeah yeah pro you know um
i'm pro-choice i'm i'm one of those guys
but um christopher's a legit but
crenshaw crenshaw is a [ __ ] guy who i
i know
i like that he's reasonable so it's out
he he took on the people saying the
election was stolen he was like this is
[ __ ] no it's not yeah and he got a
lot of [ __ ] for that so that's that's
what i know about him i don't know about
the other i haven't looked into his
[ __ ] policies i know he's republican
in houston i think he also got [ __ ]
he's about the vaccine as well
well no i think he's pro vaccine his
name i don't know yeah so am i so the
[ __ ] am i i mean in terms of like i
think i believe in science yeah
but
what's funny is that i posted uh uh i
you never know if when a hero's gonna
come out well i'm not saying he's a hero
because he's a politician i'm saying
he's a hero because he did five [ __ ]
tours and lost his size
and then kept beating he's a legend and
after he lost his sight he he went back
into the seals and did other [ __ ] he's a
monster like come on so what you got lit
up and kind of i don't know i don't look
at you yeah yeah but my friend
i've been defending you for the past
hour i was like on what like i never
know so i'm fired up yeah i'm a little
fired up because i don't like being
cancer
yeah some far far-right republican
[ __ ] off
i'm moderate as [ __ ] yeah but you should
expect that if you post a picture with
of crenshaw yeah we're so political now
we're so [ __ ] political you know we
post a picture with [ __ ] trump you
should expect some backlash he's not
trump and he's a great guy he's not
trump he's a thoughtful dude very
thoughtful dude and a good guy he just
said come on man i know you're smart on
this don't give up
this is where i get it maybe maybe uh
people are just so anti-republican in
general and link him to trump i get that
i'm not a trump supporter any republican
trump yeah yeah well i i've been very
clear on yeah i mean you gotta whoever
gives a [ __ ] yeah who cares you should
expect that i know i i i i actually if i
take a picture with pelosi i would
expect a little background right yeah i
think of him as different i think him as
a veteran who lost his eye that's what i
think a navy seal he did a [ __ ] but it's
all of it but he's a he's a politician
yeah he's a representative yeah
congressman
yeah it's just interesting we are we're
in a political world i was like whoa did
he show you his uh i don't know yeah
yeah he
showed you we hung out afterwards just
grabbed beers and stuff very
down-to-earth guy and he had a fake eye
with the uh trident
yeah does he take it out and like show
you no no but it was there at first i
didn't know what it was it looked so
often and he was like it's just the
truth remember he hit kind of mainstream
because uh davidson made fun of him
and he went super viral after that have
you seen his eye no it's so he there's
pictures of it online it's so dope he
has uh the trident i know i've seen the
try i'm saying i won't see it without
all that [ __ ] i think there's i've seen
the fake guy oh you want to take that
thing out off
there you go dope yeah that's a captain
america one
oh he has different ones he like
switches out oh hell yes
i like his ipad he looks [ __ ] sick
yeah he takes it off you know when he
goes out to drink it i think it must be
a pain to have it on all the time but
the eye patch i think so it's a
conversation
is he married and he's got problems with
his other rights you see it there uh
poor guy yeah he he that's a guy anybody
i know who [ __ ] sacrificed their eyes
for my country
he's okay
i'm not talking about politics
i'm not a trump supporter don't don't
don't link me into that [ __ ] i'm just
saying you gotta calm down i i will i
i'm a little fighter would you please i
gotta enter
we
the other side's gonna get upset it's
like if i post a picture of the boss in
red sock i'm assuming the yankee fans
are gonna talk to you yes yeah it didn't
dawn on me really yeah i'm [ __ ]
clueless 60.
i know i i'm not i'm just i don't know i
didn't think of it that way i thought of
it i think it was a navy seal who lost
his eye i don't follow his my politics i
don't follow texas politics yeah